i just uh
i always want to support my friends and
so he called me and wanted me to support
him and so on here i am
do you give him any advice on making a
concert you're no stranger to
doing these things man i just want him
to have fun and do what he loves
and i just got his back regardless
yeah he's you know evolving into film
and doing other things
that's got to make you feel good for
your friend right that he's like
pursuing
creative dreams yeah it does it makes me
feel really good
so over the past year i've been shooting
a lot of uh you know virtual concerts
trying to get
you know figure out a way to connect
with my fans via performances even
though i can't be there in person
and so i started filming my my concerts
myself and
learned a lot about lighting a lot about
cinematography and
eventually a lot about editing and so
this this film was actually
it was shot in 2017 about four years ago
and uh
it kind of just sat on the shelf because
i wasn't happy with the edit
uh until i dug it back up about three
and a half weeks ago and
did it myself this is uh the first time
that anybody's done a concert film that
was
specifically intended to be filmed for a
theater
it's uh yeah a lot of concert films that
you end up catching end up being
a tour that was already going on and
somebody decides to throw up a couple
cameras but this was a one-off show shot
on a sound stage at center space in
chicago
it's a one of a kind stage design that's
never been seen before
and the most important thing is the
sound of the whole film the uh
the audience that was there for the live
show
was completely mic'd up we hung hanging
mics and did floor mics for all of them
so that we could capture their voices
for the final product and when you go
into the theater it feels like a real
concert
it feels like something you've never
seen before but it's very familiar
i would say i'm more of a i'm a i'm a
filmmaker now
i'm trying to continue to create art and
i think
you know the difference between an actor
and a movie star is an actor
creates and they've you know they
interpret a script
build a character from the ground up and
uh
and explain it to the audiences in the
best way so that they
completely and uh you know in suspended
disbelief and so
that's what i'm trying to create with my
movies and uh
i think i think i did something pretty
good with this one
you